okay
good morning everyone it's great to see
you all
and human rights
so let me be very clear
russia is committing war crimes
right
now
even as we are sitting here in our
embassy in washington
and in addition to causing widespread
destruction and death
putin's war is having a profound impact
on the global economy
putin's war is causing food prices to
rise
his war is causing energy prices to rise
it is driving
inflation higher
worldwide
the economic consequences of putin's war
are hitting the most vulnerable around
the world the hardest
over the past few days i've been
speaking with international counterparts
about how we can all take further action
to support ukraine
and to raise the cost of russia's
aggression
putin and his henchmen must feel the
consequences of their illegal and
barbaric war
canada is glad to have taken a leading
role in establishing an administered
account for ukraine at the imf earlier
this month
providing donors with a secure vehicle
to direct financial assistance to the
ukrainian government
canada has now proposed to offer one
billion canadian dollars in support
through the administered account
we announced that in our recent budget
together with this latest contribution
canada has now provided more than 1.6
billion dollars in loans and grants
directly to the ukrainian government to
help ukraine and the ukrainian
government continue to operate in the
face of this illegal war
we've also contributed more than 900
million dollars in military aid
including 500 million dollars
announced in our recent budget
um
and after that
rebuilding ukraine
will be an immense task
this will be perhaps the greatest
political undertaking of this decade for
all rules-based democracies
said hiyu i want you to know that canada
will play its part in addition to the
grave challenge posed by russia's war on
ukraine i had the chance this week to
talk with my colleagues about the
importance of continuing to help the
world's most vulnerable countries
recover from the covid pandemic
and build
resilience
canada announced this week that we will
provide
2.4 billion dollars in new loan
commitments and a 40 a 40 million dollar
grant to the imf's resilience and
sustainability
trust
this is in addition to canada's previous
contribution of
984 million dollars to the imf's poverty
reduction and growth trust
these contributions together with our
support for ukraine through the imf
account mean that canada has now
exceeded our commitment to channel 20
of our sdrs
so
uh this week specifically i've attended
the g20 finance ministers and central
bank governors meeting the g7 finance
ministers and central banks governors
meetings
the international monetary and financial
committee meetings
the financial action task force
ministerial meeting
and the world bank ministerial
roundtable on support to ukraine which i
attended together with my colleague
minister sajin i also had a number of
bilateral meetings with
the u.s secretary of the treasury janet
yellen
with germany's minister of finance
christian lindner
with the deputy prime minister and
minister of finance of the netherlands
sigrid cog
with sweden's minister of finance
mikhail damberg
with the first deputy prime minister and
minister for the economy of spain nadia
calvinio with the executive vice
president of the european commission
valdis dombrovskis
with the secretary general of the oecd
matias corman with the president of the
world bank david malpass
with the prime minister of ukraine
dennis mihal
and of course with ukraine's finance
minister siddhi marchenko
who is here with us today at our embassy
siddhi will speak next um
but before he does and with his
permission
i wanted to share
something personal about him
uh
said he comes from
the town of makhadev
which is a small town to the west of
cave
makariv was
part of the regions around cave that
were occupied by russia during the
effort
to conquer k youth
the apartment where said he was born
has been destroyed
his family home the home of his late
grandfather was destroyed
his family
was there
during the occupation and
they know personally what it's like
um
it was very uh it affected me very much
to hear said he who is the finance
minister of ukraine uh talked to me
about that
um but he did tell me that his parents
are now back
uh
in their village home
and they are planting potatoes because
that's what you do in april in ukraine
i hand it over to sidhi martin ko the
finance minister of ukraine
thank you very much
dear
wasa prime minister minister of finance
of canada
dear colleagues
first and foremost
let me sincerely thank
you christian for your support of
ukraine and for
all my heart i want to tell you that
we think that
that canadian supports the support of
canadian
people which we see right now is
unprecedented and for that i want to
thank you
and want to tell you that
we are struggling
and we are combating this war and we no
way we will win this war
we have very good expectations from
previous meetings
and our government is
full operational
in the first day of war we
provided necessary step to relocate our
critical infrastructure to the west of
ukraine to spread our peoples throughout
ukraine
and we have been able to do necessary
steps to
give
necessary flows of money to our people
we paid pensions paid salaries
paid necessary expenses for military
and also we service our debt
and
also uh worth mentioning that
now we're here not just
to meet
uh great leader of financial world we
are here to explain our situation in
ukraine where we see drastic
causes of russia
unprovoked innovation in ukraine
russian atrocities
what they have done i can't even explain
you know it quite well but a lot of
civilian people were killed
women's children's
and
i'm here because of my mission my
mission is here to
to show to explain
for all people around the world that we
need your support
not only military support but financial
as well it needs the support from a very
short period of time
we believe that this bridge
to the normal
can help us to
reshape our economy
and again
to
help our budget to be balanced
because pre-war our
budget was fully balanced
we expected this year to have
three percent of gdp budget deficit
our depth
gdp ratio was 450 percent so our macro
financial stability and fiscal
stability were in a good shape
and again again i want to iterate that
i'm here to attract attention to ukraine
and to gain necessary support
and again to want to thank you
christopherlind is a great friend of
ukraine
he
have done a lot of
necessary steps to show all people
around the world that ukraine is not
alone
and thank you again for for your support
and your
impressive
speeches
towards all members of g7 g20 countries
and
my last maybe my message before you can
ask questions i i want to reiterate
again that we expected that
countries
which now presented in spring meetings
when they returned back to home
make some collective actions towards
ukraine
we needed this very much we needed this
support because our estimation
around 5 billion
gap of our deficit needed to finance
so
again and again
i would have preferred to speak with you
in a more peaceful condition but when i
realized in my countries bombing
sheltering and you know the situation in
mariopol
is very
i can't even use
nice word for this and
so
let
me be
kind and polite and show that we are
here
we are
functional and i believe that ukraine
somehow sometimes
go
would be part of the great nations
thank you very much
okay
thank you sidhio and we'll now turn the
floor over to our minister of
international development who knows
ukraine very well uh heart sergeant
heart thank you deputy prime minister
and thank you minister um marchenko
over the past months the world has stood
shoulder to shoulder with the ukrainian
people as their country has been
threatened because of vladimir putin
civilians have been killed
schools and hospitals have been targeted
and atrocities are currently being
committed
and despite the urgent needs
in cities like mariopol
humanitarian assistance has been denied
because of russian actions
and while
and while here at the imf the world bank
meets i've spoken with many of my
counterparts and we spoke about russia's
unjustifiable invasion of ukraine and
that has caused the biggest shock of the
global food systems in the past 12 years
global food prices have hit the highest
levels on record in march since march 20
march 2022
meaning that because of vladimir putin
more people in more countries are going
hungry now
now especially girls and women who
invariably eat
eat the least
and they eat last
now we as a global community need to
come together to ensure that no person
goes hungry
and with global food prices thirty
percent higher than in january and over
sixty percent hires since before of the
before the pandemic
we need to strengthen the resilience of
global food systems it is why canada has
provided 1.9 billion dollars in funding
over the past three years to improve the
food systems resilience
and i said to my counterparts
we will continue to be there for the
people of ukraine
and we will continue to be there for
those impacted by the hunger and the
food insecurity crisis that vladimir
putin has caused thank you merci
beaucoup
i just asked that
i'll just project um there's a
microphone at the back of the room
[Music]
ukrainian interpretation yes
oh thank you very much dmitry an option
ukrainian television uh i got a question
for both the ministers and let me speak
ukrainian and if i may can ask you to
answer ukrainian
just to give my audience audience in
ukraine the possibility to hear you
without any interpretation
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
can you put it on the agenda can you
also work with canada in order to
um address this issue is it translation
was not
uh
um
investment i think this would be a
better policy
especially for our creditors
[Music]
and also i would like to tell to the
ukrainian people
canada
would say the whole democratic world
we understand our responsibility
responsibility regarding ukraine and the
ukrainian people
we understand that this war is on
ukrainian soil
and
the ukrainian men and women
fight
defend ukraine and die but we understand
that you
defend
the whole world you defend us
you defend the democracy the principles
of international law and i would like
the ukrainian people to hear from us
that we understand
that it's not only the ukraine's
responsibility to finance this
war
and it's not only ukraine's
responsibility to rebuild ukraine
good morning thank you for coming and
inviting us this morning appreciate it
um
mr freeland we saw today that or this
week that you and others uh left the g20
finance plenary when russia tried to
intervene do you think the gt the g20
should kick russia out and if so what
would the process be to do that
yes i do
and
that is a view
that was clearly expressed by
all of our leading allies
uh in the meeting and in bilateral
conversations there was canada was very
clear and many of our partners were very
clear
that
russia
does not have a place
at the table
of countries
who have come together
to
maintain global economic prosperity
and to maintain a global
economy
governed by rules
you can't be a poacher and a game keeper
at the same time
you can't be violating
probably the most fundamental principle
which is in the u.n charter
which is the foundation of our ability
as countries to work together
and that principle is
you don't
invade and try to take over another
country
having violated that principle and
continuing to violate it with an ongoing
war
it's impossible
to talk about international
collaboration international cooperative
efforts with russia
and what is the process for that though
we need to be clear
and we are
with canadians and with each other
that
this is our view
i think the meetings this week were very
important because it was an opportunity
for
a wide group of countries
to talk about it
in groups and bilaterally
and also to make clear
as
we did
when we left the g20 meeting when we
left the imfc plenary
that we simply
will not be part of meetings while
russia is speaking
just one for the thing on the diplomatic
front the uk has announced it will
reopen its embassy in keefe
soon will canada
last night
i had a very useful meeting with denis
mihal
the ukrainian prime minister
and we discussed a wide range of issues
one of them was
the question of a diplomat of
embassies in caith
prime minister shmi hall talked to me
about
the
efforts that the ukrainian government is
making
to restore regular life in cave and
you've heard minister martinko speaking
about it also
and he talked about
how the ukrainian government is working
very hard to make it safe and possible
for embassies to return to cave so we
had a good conversation about it
i look forward to
coming back to canada
uh and
sharing uh what prime minister shmi hall
shared with me
yes possibly
that say we're talking about it and we
hear our ukrainian friends
uh good morning voice of america
ukrainian service irena matvichuk a
short follow-up on g20 question uh
are you uh some countries
could veto
uh
exclusion russia from g20 are you
working with countries like china and
other countries
on this issue and also um
could you please provide more specifics
on heavy artillery shipment to ukraine
that canadian prime minister announced
yesterday
what amount of money was allocated for
this and any specifics would be very
helpful and also a question to
panmarchenko
minister of finance how do you propose
that ukraine attracts
these um
millions of dollars billions of dollars
uh to support ukraine what kind of
strategy do you have to rebuild ukraine
and specifically from the financial
standpoint
collect the funds so when it comes to
the g20 uh
the meetings this week
at the g20 but also at the imf
were very helpful
when it comes
to giving countries a chance to make
clear
their position on russia's illegal war
there were a range of positions uh
expressed obviously
but one thing came through very clearly
and that is that
the entire world
is
bearing the consequences of russia's
illegal war
these were the imf world bank meetings
and so the focus was very much on the
economy
the global economy is hurting
because of russia's illegal war
in ukraine
and that is not acceptable
it was important for all of us to be
able to talk about that
uh in terms of military aid from canada
to ukraine
we have now contributed more than 900
million dollars of military aid to
ukraine
that includes a specific allocation
which i announced when i tabled the
canadian budget
i guess it was two weeks ago now
of 500 million dollars specifically
earmarked to provide
military aid weapons to ukraine that's
what the prime minister and our minister
of defense have been talking about and
this does give me an opportunity
particularly for
ukrainian journalists
to highlight the very important personal
role
that my colleague minister sajan
played as minister of defense
in supporting developing operation
unifier
hi good good morning
sorry
can you hear me a lot of
centers right now
concerning the croatian
recovery fund
which can be vehicle to support
recovery of ukraine
and now
now
we are looking at this perspective
described deciding what it should be
best for ukraine because we see
the incentive from european union to
create solidarity fund
also you know that ukraine
created u-24 recovery fund so now we
just need to match this incentive
together because
also united states canada provided us
some
mechanism how we can move in this
direction
what is concerns the most is russian
assets frozen russian assets
and we eager to find a way how to save
this
assets towards ukrainian fund
to rebuild ukraine to recover ukraine
let's see how it will be thank you
hi good good morning i'm david lauter
with reuters news service here based
here in washington d.c i actually have
questions for all three of you so um
minister martinko um
the
uh pledges have been have been
coming through uh but your president
yesterday said that ukraine needs seven
billion dollars per month
just to keep its economy going
uh do you think um you know that
canada's now pledging a billion dollars
the united states is pledging a billion
dollars
that doesn't seem like it's going to be
enough uh what needs to be done to scale
that up
um
and uh minister freeland if you could
just follow up on the g20 um discord
issue
there is
has been really no communiques issued
this this this week we can't you know
ministers can't agree on on putting
things in writing is that a problem for
these these forums going forward if you
if you
cannot get
communiques out to really say what it is
you agree on um and then mr saigon um
you've talked about food security um
today indonesia has announced that it is
um
suspending exports of palm oil which is
its its largest export and a huge
uh food oil
uh
source and uh because ukraine is not
able to export its sunflower oil so
is that a problem does that sort of go
against the uh you know trying to avoid
a food security crisis thank you
thank you very much for your questions
we have prepared and shared with our
partners
our figures of our budget i just want to
reiterate it we lost 50 of our revenues
our
current revenues can cover only 54
of our existing needs excluding military
excluding service in debt
so
the right figures our partners received
now we are waiting for a right decision
smart decision from
their side so i am not want to push
somebody to do some actions uh we have a
lot of different
actions to do within the countries
is if we are not received enough money
to support ukraine but we eager to
expect that
as canada
provided good examples other countries
shows
the same
behavior
on the g20
yes it is the case
that the g20
can't function effectively with russia
at the table and with russia in the room
it's an absurd situation
because
the central challenge which the global
economy is facing right now
is russia's illegal invasion of ukraine
and we can't really talk about it with
russia in the group
unless and until russia takes the right
decision
which is
to end its invasion to withdraw from
ukraine
having said that
the meetings in washington this week
have been extremely productive
they've been a chance for all of us to
hear directly
from minister martin kawa from prime
minister
mihai what is happening
what ukraine needs and what ukraine's
plans are that's been really useful
and it has also been a chance
for
the other g20 countries to talk to each
other
to make clear our respective positions
and
to talk about how to proceed
and i want to say one thing um about
food if i may and
minister machinko might also want to
comment just from the ukrainian
perspective one of the things that we
learned
from minister martinko
is
that really a big part of the food
challenge is not
that the food doesn't exist in ukraine
uh ukraine had a successful harvest in
the fall
there's a lot of food in ukraine
waiting
to be shipped
to the hungry people of the world
and so the challenge really is about
finding a way to open up ukraine's ports
and that's a challenge
that that
is really at the heart of the world's
food security challenge i'll turn it
over to heart
to answer your questions about the the
challenges
they mean inside ukraine the people are
suffering and vladimir putin's uh
warning ukraine is also uh creating
suffering around the world uh people are
they're um
they're already
stretched because the pandemic
and now the food security crisis because
the ukraine was also bad bread basket
for the world and i had
our team already early on looked at the
percentage of um
ukrainian wheat in uh was going to the
number of developing countries
that is going to uh be zero right now
unless those ports are open
um so we'll be having a greater
discussion uh later on this month i
spoke with many counterparts here at the
world bank as well
on what we need to do to uh to mitigate
this
so this
one of the things is the deputy prime
minister just mentioned the ports
opening
would make a significant contribution uh
in in terms of the humanitarian crisis
that's actually taking place around the
world as well so that's one thing but
also other nations will step up
including canada to look at uh other uh
ways how we can provide support and
other nations who um
uh
when it comes to the actual wheat we
also have to take a look at what needs
to be uh planted next year so the the
fertilizer is also going to be a
significant uh uh challenge as well so
all these things are being taken into
account the rest of the world is is
coming to um together and we call on
vladimir putin
to allow those ports to be open so that
the the world does not go hungry
the i think um that's the uh a difficult
question to answer for for other for
other countries i know that every
country is going to have to look at um
or their needs but most of my the the
counterparts i've spoken to are also
doing their part um they're also looking
after people but they're also making
efforts to be able to support the rest
of the world as well and this is where
we're gonna have to come together more
work is gonna have to be done on this
but i'm not going to speak for other
countries but i know that canada will
definitely be stepping up
good morning i'm from ukrainian outlet
so let me uh ask you to answer in
ukrainian for our audience um
minister you said that ukraine needs
urgent help
for the next three months we heard that
the deficit budget deficits is 5 billion
we heard that the united states and
canada will do
their contributions but can you tell
that for this for the next three months
there is some kind of guarantee
that uh
this account will be
filled with funds
also panic christie can you say
that okay
can you guarantee that ukraine will not
be left alone
the war is continuing and other
countries will have their own issues um
thank you very much for your
[Music]
do we have guarantees and pledges for
funds can we be
quiet uh so to speak
i am hoping so
we are hoping that the support of
international partners will continue to
be strong we do our homework uh we're
working hard to make sure that we'll be
able to pay the pensions uh support our
army
pays salaries
and
um i'm sure that we will do that
i would like
to be firm give a firm answer canada
will not leave ukraine alone we really
understand
that this war
it's our war
and we understand very well
and we want to express our thanks
it's only ukrainians only ukrainian men
and women
who fight who
pay with their lives
you die but we understand that you fight
for us and we have the moral
responsibility
but apart from the moral responsibility
we have the practical responsibility um
it's very important for us to see
ukraine win to see ukraine's victory
and for that we understand that you need
weapons you need funds and you need
sanctions and we're working
we're working on it
um
what are the diplomatic relations what
are the diplomatic the diplomatic
discussions between
the next question is for you uh where
are the negotiations the diplomatic
negotiation between ukraine and russia
right now
um joe biden yesterday said this war
will be very long
as mrs freeland said uh earlier she said
the the war is in ukraine ukrainians are
actually dying um you're fighting a war
for everyone
so where do you see where do you see
this going in terms of diplomatic
resolution
and mr sargan as well please
perhaps i'll ask mr martinko to start
because this
is uh as a question for him
and
canada's diplomatic role as well
you know i
not part of negotiating team so
i don't um
have a mandate to discuss
how this conflict could be resultant
but what i tell you like ukrainian
citizens ukrainian minister of finance
that
we need
to be
ready to convert that last meter of
ukrainian territory to be
again
to our sovereignty
and
we see right now that russia
should
negate negotiating a good faith they
don't
so let's see how it will be
today
because
we have to underscore
that every day
since the beginning of the war
we're experiencing a human tragedy
and that's very important to underscore
this
you're talking about the sovereignty of
ukraine that was violated
and it's extremely important
with russia
[Music]
are also
to russia
thank you christian
i had the privilege
for over six years
to travel to ukraine
as part of the
as we built up the training mission
and one thing as we talk about weapon
systems i just want to note
the bravery of the ukrainian armed
forces i saw that on my first visit
it wasn't and the first briefing that i
received was that why did
the troops here there don't need a lot
of training
what they need is we we train some of
them and then they train their own so we
were able to quickly expand that
training
to adding new systems and
and also to increase the numbers up to
uh we were up to i think almost a
brigade and the rapid response brigade
was one of the areas that we focused on
and why do i say this is
when when you when you look at the pride
in in the people's eyes and i got to
travel the country i guess because we
expanded our mission all across the
country rather than people them coming
to us in the west we actually went um to
to the front um close enough to the
front to be able to train them
um ultimately it was their decision to
make
and i used to get asked questions well
what do you think
where things should go i said no this is
not a decision for us this is a decision
for the ukrainian people and i just want
to say how proud i am for the bravery
that the ukrainian armed forces
have shown
but one thing i do call on i do call on
russia to open up the humanitarian
corridors
people are suffering there are
international laws
that we all abide by and russia should
be abiding by them and the world will
hold them to account for all the
atrocities that have been committed
thank you
before people leave yes
before people leave i want to speak
ukrainian
i want to introduce a very important
canadian
person kirsten
excuse me our ambassador to washington
dc to the us she's the key person in our
government she took part in our meetings
with ukraine and our meetings with
international partners
with me with the
minister of defense it was hard
for her because there are two ministers
but i also want the ukrainians to see
her and to
acknowledge her work